first let me start with congratulations
movie is so
good uh i'm a big fan of soderbergh and
i'm curious if you could share
what it was maybe what surprised you
about working with him on this film
like uh that maybe fans would like to
hear about you know he's incredibly
efficient and i'm sure you've
you've heard from other people too i
mean when you when
filmmakers say shoot what you need and
you know just you know be efficient and
don't waste time and don't hose down a
scene
like he he literally just shoots what
shoots what he needs like
i mean to almost to a point where as a
filmmaker it kind of made me anxious to
be quite honest when i was like
you might need a wide of this he's like
no i don't because he edits his own
stuff he's shooting it and he's editing
it so he's on the camera not just
dp and he's not just the dp he's
actually camera upping
the whole entire film which is i've
never i've
i've done a few times but only on like
tiny tiny indie stuff you know
yeah i'll just echo that that having him
behind the camera when you're this close
to him
um you sort of like there's not a
there's a lot of trust like i feel like
once he hires someone he's like
i'm trusting you to do the job i hired
you for
um so there's like it's really fast
so there wasn't like a lot of talking on
set there wasn't like a ton of direction
it was just sort of you can kind of like
read him
because he's right there behind the
camera um and there's not a lot of takes
and so um you really are given like a
lot of
i don't know autonomy while knowing he's
getting exactly what's
what he's wants and what's in his head
or he would
you know change it up one of the things
that i
uh loved about ed solomon's script was
everything but if i was being specific
i would say that the way it weaves in
real history with these small-time
criminals
for both of you could you talk about
what you responded to most with the
script
what you're excited for people to see i
think the most exciting
is that how many twists and turns it
takes and every
every time you think you have a handle
on what's happening
it subverts that expectation and uses
you know the classic format of of like a
heist movie
and and becomes extremely informative
but also
just keeps like like turning and
twisting and
and giving you new you know new or new
exciting like
information not just about like the car
industry which i didn't know about but
also
uh about each character and sort of
their motivation for everything
yeah each character was so layered and
you understood
the motivation for why they're
participating
um in sort of these criminal behaviors
you know and then like ultimately where
we end up which i won't give it away
um just like the scandal within the car
industry
you're like oh there were such specific
terrible conditions that a lot of these
characters were experiencing that all
led them to these choices
and i thought that like layering that
complex
um layering was just like so extremely
well done and hard to do
completely agree i have to go good luck
with the rest of your interviews
uh and have a fantastic day congrats on
the movie
thanks